okay welcome to this video l marmalade
Grandmaster mug aroma let's see what
he's doing here in this game 10g tends
to play a sharp stuff now this is not so
sure but it's totally fine for black a
line that I also do recommend for the
black player against them and this so g3
opening i recently had this with black I
just think that I probably I probably
had given a temper at one point with
black like age six or something yeah the
debt that was happening in my game as
well when I had like him and I got got
very good compensation for black as
black anyway what can you do that this
looks pretty awkward for for for me in
some way but I have one thing in my
favor this is this move this IDM that
this is six porn is attacked and f5 is
also under pressure so yeah let's just
take this can I just go Quincy three and
try to keep that pawn with before it's
got 97 be for Bishop of six maybe hmm
look a five is also something that might
happen okay let's um get this on a
decent scram he probably can get to get
the porn with Luke a five or something
like that no no 97 this kind of moves
will get the pawn back if it doesn't do
that i might get in quincy three and
before ok so he wants to wants to take
it understandably okay let's go back on
a on a normal let's say square and go
from there
sure f6 I didn't expect maybe night
before awesome was it wasn't looking at
f5 and the checking d5 okay I can also
just take c 6-r queen be true I am but
that's rather lame that's really lame
there's something better Roxy 294 hoopty
to
okay let's do this maybe just a for a
for soon okay so much for a four
yeah that's it feels rather draw I think
what can I do something here this one or
I didn't expect that move at all why is
this working at all c6 is hanging now
aunt is in a pin so you cannot take you
three so easily plus a3 is hanging so
yeah I have Bishop Bishop c6 at least ok
let's do it let's not spend much more
time and now just back rook c8 is also
means that it's possible now sometimes I
also threaten looked you one I think
just pinning that porn
and maybe I should have taken over the
rook actually intend a look-see form and
keeping that discovery with the bishop
and I probably was a bad move okay I try
to be a bit more practical now and be be
quicker with moving tix don't get it
takes on what 110 Queen takes on look
you one then one two three
I didn't really think much when i played
this move i have to admit yeah exactly
if it is that not sure what my movers
spit bit annoying kicks yeah that's by
far not idea no 94 I could have played
better probably this I did not expect
but it's not a bad idea I guess hmm
don't have any Trixie annoyed and
probably not check
check
time morning is the group t7 that might
be might be a move here yeah I am that's
that's not good hmm that's not good at
all if u 1 93 takes takes takes and it's
that's bad the worst is i spend lots of
time on that I hoped you one okay maybe
it maybe it works maybe that works
bishop is covering it too as well 92 as
a move though and then i take c jack
okay jack
a magic meet it somewhere g4 it's almost
made wow wow Jack Black forfeits on time
Wow whoo-chow Oh a very tough game some
stupid time when okay let's let's see
somewhere out here and I worry will you
wonder what was going on I probably at
Bishop c6 was probably someone stupid
and this this pack is good and now I
should probably take with the brook
another computer he likes the smooth and
wants to go look see for now I am that
that was a but probably you too quick
this move Roxy for as good threatening
this this actually wins for what let's
plus plus to point something a black
runs out of moves this is a big threat
ready it takes and then d5 immediately
okay I didn't see that and here I have
check and before yep here I only thought
about night takes but this is fine and
the engine shapes equal no it says I'm
winning push up a three yeah very bad
I'm just I'm just dropping this one
bad game yeah so there was some some
situations where I really had a win
which I did not see then I 192 wins of
course I didn't see that chaplet this
okay so this is not as winning as the
other one but this was a shocking move
really shocking GG for KH for the nessus
92 made idea for example if a chick here
then you threatened this an IG to mate I
didn't see move and Bishop t5s is ok
with equal yeah this losses but I mean I
was panicking check he took this and y
an idea three is made actually i only
had I can only give brooke g 1 meter i
can only desperado here a couple of
capture of pieces and then getting
checkmated so talk about being saved by
the bell but in hectic end of it ok
thanks for watching